[Music]
and stay put new some submitted by is
it's either I glove JK or IG love JK
gotta love JK German schools are facing
criticism for using 13 pound sand vests
to keep hyper kids Hooters that's [ __ ]
dope I love that wait they're facing
criticism so they're not getting a
thumbs up they get a thumbs up from me
me too because they have those for
doggies when the doggies are anxious
they have the weighted vests and then it
comes down to doggies cuz I like it
because it's productive and it makes
them work out harder yeah so if the kids
are they have a lot of energy then let
them have a little workout throughout
the day and they're just gonna build
like stronger little bodies because your
bodies can handle and they can handle
more of the caloric expenditure I like
it why do they it's a workout angle yeah
for me it's just like like some kids
they're just more energetic than others
right so some people they need a two
hour workout some people need a 20 30
minute workout well if you got to learn
and stay in the classroom all day long
and do the same [ __ ] then it's kind of
like when people do a Spartan Race it's
the same race some people are spreading
the [ __ ] out of it some people are
walking it it's the same classroom you
might as well give some kids that can
handle a lot more a little vest and
people that can just sit there they
don't need a vest oh good question they
don't really mention the age but they
are mentioning that there are about 200
schools in Germany that are using these
vest is it like a straitjacket where the
kids are just like it's a weighted vest
so it feels like a bulletproof vest yeah
like a little workout vest so they're
between two point seven pounds 13 no
workout fast that [ __ ] looks [ __ ]
dope it looks like this kid is playing
SWAT with a [ __ ] bunny regiment
workout this that's about 13 pounds does
it ever because they're wearing it all
day does that would that ever mess up
they're like back or anything their
growth but there's also a range right so
it might be H specific like if they're
like 5 you wear the two-pound one or if
you're in junior high or
dirty mama yeah but even to wear it all
day I feel like that's very
uncomfortable for eight hours maybe not
all of it
Oh baby until they call it a sit-down
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] you know what
else would work if I got spooned from
the back from a very warm overweight
auntie way what would work no like if if
if I'm just like oh like that right and
then the designated Spooner will sit
down and then I sit on the aunties lat
and then she spoons me like this then
I'll like calm down that's how the
perverts what can happen pervert yeah
yeah but like I'm not gonna rape the
auntie well what about an uncle is it
awkward to give you a hug
well I don't want to sit on a dick so
it's got to be an auntie and plus
there's gonna be titties so I could
relax into it yeah but it could still be
a possibility of people being like it
was inappropriate why people take it
they're fine I just I'm just trying to
be creative yeah I felt like I needed
something like this as a kid because I
couldn't I couldn't sit still and then I
was always trying to get different
angles of the class so sometimes I'm
like just in the middle of class I'm
looking at the teacher like this oh it's
getting trouble cuz I'm moving around
but if you made it harder for me to move
around then I might actually get tired
if I stood up if I went to go hide in
the closet or play with the petrol it
was like a punishment though a little
bit for me really but that's why um but
if you're also viewing it as a
punishment but that's why well maybe
your mom didn't do this but in beeping
I'll image school anyways before school
started they had faculty up there so
kids could play around for the first 30
minutes for the unit so parents would
bring them earlier they get to run
around getting all the energy out and
they would go to class my mom had me run
two laps around the neighborhood every
single morning to get rid of my hasn't
been there worse but I did exercise
before school started
me too I did there was a class workout
in the morning like they would play that
you come to heart step but butter up
every single morning and then we would
just be like those oh don't be like this
aerobic guy and it will follow his stuff
and in every morning did you guys have
the that fruity jump rope guy come to
your school no all right well there'll
be this guy that was dressed up in like
rainbow spandex and they would do all
these crazy jump rope checks and they
would
like get us to try to do that [ __ ] I
could start laughing at him
no but I want to go back on to what you
say so you feel like it's more about
punishment huh a little bit just cuz I
feel like so we know that these kids
need an education obviously think about
me baby boy so so thinking about baby
parts then I feel like in the curriculum
at least it should be like um cuz I feel
like there's enough study where I feel
like his attention span is only good for
so long right like when we have our
creative circles we can only do it for
like at least three hours right after
three hours you're tapped out you're
doing that you're doing it I like you
imagine like oh yeah yeah that's cool
but the power
it just seems no I don't even I look at
his movements because and then you're
like oh but I'm thinking about the kids
what if they kiss just getting used to
the way that he's better know I will be
able to move freely
[Music]
yeah you wake us up no but I think there
are people there are parents that feel
the way you do do and so they're saying
for example this one parent said quote
it would be best if we avoided such
torture methods how can you say oh it's
torture that's like oh that's a little
too extreme that's a bitch-ass parent
yeah then they say how can you say to a
child you're sick and as a punishment
you have to wear the sand-filled jacket
which anyone said they're sick but this
parent does though this place indistinct
which is not only physical agony but
will make you look like an idiot in
front of the rest of the class I'll put
the idiot stuff that stuff doesn't look
that cute and I feel like if you're the
only one wearing it then everyone's
gonna be like oh there goes a DD Joe
where it is special as vest and I'm like
even though I like it a little bit it's
gonna be cool to help kids that have
ADHD so like super hyper they just can't
seem to focus on their work cuz they're
just always like so jiggly like Wiggly
and stuff but there is this one mother
who said that her son has been using it
for the past three years and she says
that nigga's calves in class she says
that he can concentrate better and he's
more able to take on active part in
lessons because he's not spending the
whole time trying to keep his arms and
legs under control cuz he's being
weighted I wish I had something like
this because it took me a long time to
start learning I don't think I started
learning until college did you ever get
pets a long time
did they ever put you on medication or
are you art no because I don't think my
parents recognized that there was a
problem or they didn't even know that
there's this thing called a DD that
exists so the more I haven't been
diagnosed but the more I see like or
hear from my family about how I was as a
kid and like the diagnosis and like
taking psychology and learning what the
the the the traits of a TD is or ADHD I
go oh [ __ ] I probably have adult ADHD
right now
hmm how about you Bart were you ever on
medication they prescribe medication to
my mom and told me to get it but then
did you go to a school psychologist or
counselor or some school psychologist
but my mom being the mom that she is she
took me home and lit incense and tried
to perform an exorcism perfect and try
to get the ADHD demon out of me aren't
you glad that she did that because now
you're not dependent on drugs and
instead you found a different vice which
is physical activity yeah well most
people are supposed to grow out of it in
their adulthood years yeah for me I
think like in my 30s I'm finally
starting to calm down I don't know about
that that's a better way than before I
was like what's going on over here
I probably leave and be outside yeah
yeah so these schools are saying that
these vets are better than just met like
medicating all the kids ritalin I'd
rather do that to medicate I agree with
that I know I kind of went out I don't
believe in what was it not adrenaline at
at all at all at all yeah I don't know I
don't believe in any of those drugs that
shit's meth yeah why are you gonna give
children meth as a same chemical
compound as meth it's cuz it balances
out the chemical [ __ ] I don't know but
that's only if you're like if you choose
to perceive it as an imbalance hmm I
didn't ask the part that's messed up or
like everyone's categorizing kids as
this and and if the kid is more
energetic or less energetic now they're
like oh let's medicate them to make them
fit in within these lines right and I
feel like the vest is actually a
productive way of making them fit within
these lines so the teacher can do their
job without having to change any type of
chemical balance in the body cuz I think
it's the system that's [ __ ] up not
human beings
so like ADHD is only a problem because
we need people to sit down shut the [ __ ]
up listen to the teacher for eight hours
true
that's not natural to human beings yeah
that's kids are supposed to be [ __ ]
crazy go out expend that energy and then
be focused on different things and and
it's like you're taking in all this like
information and and you're touching the
leaves and you're playing on trees
that's what we're supposed to be doing
not sitting in a classroom at six years
old being [ __ ] like still and like
robots yeah that's what I was getting at
when I was saying like when we have our
creatives like our sessions or whatever
like cuz I feel like a kid up until they
learn a little bit more logic they are
very creative creatures so for us as
adults to be able to tap into that I
feel like after two hours maybe even
three like we get cast down and we're
just like do we need a break we need a
we need a break up you didn't get out of
this room and feel the air or feel the
Sun or just have a conversation about
something else and like kind of like
what you're saying and but then yeah we
look at these traits as like negative
and whatnot but I have a theory that
they're super powers because everyone
has different traits that work in at
Vantage like some time in the past when
we were evolving like in a tribe setting
maybe when we were hunter-gatherers or
whatever maybe ADHD people had more
resilience toward like going out and
catching their prey because they never
get tired such as Michael Phelps when he
was able to just swim like a
[ __ ] because he probably forgot
how long he was swimming for so I don't
know yeah well they aren't mentioning in
this article that that psychiatrists are
skeptical like some of them are
skeptical about these vests because
they're saying that this could be seen
as a one-size-fits-all approach rather
than focusing on the individual each
child that's true that's always the
problem with my public school systems
you can you can't expect any more than
that they have to make something
standardized because there's so many
students and if that's not something
that and that's not an option
homeschooling has to be it or maybe
private schools but that's really
expensive and they don't have a money
yeah if you don't have a money you don't
have a honey
sure
[Music]
[Music]